el ministro de exteriores británico
busca garantizar que el talibán permita
un corredor humanitario de vuelos para
que los ciudadanos británicos y los
afganos elegibles para venir al reino
unido- y que se mantienen en ese país en
afganistán puedan viajar de una manera
segura desde qatar el país que está
jugando un papel bien clave en las
negociaciones entre el talibán y
occidente dominicaba el ministro de
exteriores dijo que en el futuro
predecible el reino unido no tiene
planeado reconocer un eventual gobierno
del talibán pero también aclaró que es
importante abrir esa puerta para el
diálogo sobre todo ahora que se requiere
la reapertura del aeropuerto
internacional de kabul que está sin
control está cerrado desde que las
tropas occidentales dejaron el país el
31 antes del 31 de agosto lo que se
quiere es que se permita la llegada de
vuelos chárter o vuelos comerciales para
entonces poder habilitar esa salida
segura se ha hablado de que el manejo
del aeropuerto tendría que ser a través
de un tercer país y se ha contemplado la
posibilidad de turquía pero todavía no
hay nada seguro recordemos que hace
apenas unas horas el gobierno británico
confirmó que está en negociaciones con
el talibán para permitir justamente ese
corredor humanitario pero lo cierto y lo
ha dejado muy claro tanto el primer
ministro como el secretario de
exteriores hoy que antes de reconocer un
eventual gobierno del talibán deben
comprometerse a respetar ya mantener los
derechos humanos que han ganado los
afganos en los últimos 20 años permitir
que las niñas y las mujeres puedan
seguir educándose y trabajar y también a
renunciar a permitir que su territorio
sea utilizado por grupos terroristas
para especialmente lanzar atentados
contra occidente además dominique ahora
desde qatar donde realiza una gira dijo
que visitó los centros donde están los
refugiados afganos y escucho sus
historias desgarradoras de cómo tuvieron
que salir de su país para salvar sus
vidas